foreign
[Music]
Cantor Freedom's Tick Tock allegedly
showing human rights abuses in Shanghai
it's just one of many videos critical of
China that he's posted after receiving
several warnings about his content now
he was banned on March 11th for this his
appeals were rejected until it was
brought up at last week's Tick-Tock
hearing Banning in his Canter freedom is
that an example of objectionable
material inside
the Chinese Communist party in mainland
China
we do not we do not take down contents
simply because it's critical his account
was taken off one week after we can
check on the specifics
I'll get back to you on that that was
his favorite response well Tick Tock
reinstated Cantor Freedom's account
while the hearing was happening and then
blame the American moderators for their
mistake yeah here now is the Nez Canter
Freedom human rights activist former NBA
player and as now you admit that China
uses Tick-Tock to brainwash folks but
you want to use this as a weapon against
them to expose them am I getting that
right
exactly you know first of all thank you
for having me and second I bought a
second point just for this because I
knew that if I would have download this
app on my first phone they were gonna
take all my data and listen every
conversation that I've ever had so I
bought a second phone downloaded Tick
Tock because I wanted to expose the
hypocrisy I wanted to uh you know just
go out there and you know hit him with
their own uh weapon so I downloaded Tick
Tock I actually started to post uh on
tick tock on all for all the China human
right abuses literally in one week they
Banned Me from from the app and I knew
that that was gonna the hearing was
going to happen and the CEO with CEO of
tick tock gonna actually texted one of
my congressman friends uh Carlos menager
said I was like can you please ask him
why do they ban my account just because
I was posting things about you know
humorous China's humorous violations and
while he was asking the question they
unbanned me and I actually recorded
everything
yeah so you you got you kind of uh
expose them for who they are now and as
last Thursday the CEO of tick tock
reacted to the house testimony claiming
that we're committed to providing a safe
secure platform that Fosters an
inclusive place for our amazing diverse
communities to call home it's a shame
today's conversation
um felt rooted in xenophobia that's the
classic they always go to xenophobia
you're anti-immigrant oh get out of town
you're total frauds I'm sorry I could
not stand that Mr Chu from Tick Tock
that was our if that's our future I'm
out okay if that Mr Chu and his phony
baloney nonsense was our future we're in
big trouble your reaction to all that
you know I agree 150 million people in
America just download this app and you
know China is actually using this app to
brainwash people actually manipulate our
youth you know and so we got to do
whatever I mean this app shouldn't be
banned a long time ago I mean look at
all right Western Ave like Google like
YouTube right like Twitter Instagram
Facebook they all banned in China so why
are we letting them in our country we
are worried about the Chinese spy
balloon but we literally have 150
million Chinese pop balloon right now in
our phone in our home so we gotta do
something about it yeah we either give
them access to our critical shipping
information and our supply chain
information or they can spy on us
through our Tick Tock and as uh you're
so great we love you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else